no tomatoes tomatoes tell me that him
and Chris Farley
him and Chris probably used to play this
they do this bit where it did Chris Beck
they pretend they were detectives and
Chris probably Beck oh man what do you
think happen in Chris Fargo take a pants
off let me [ __ ] your ass why cuz this is
how we're gonna figure out what happened
[Laughter]
reminds me getting pumped really from
everything that we did oh come on bro
it's so after you game she says so
rounds I gotta do squats but you've got
a great ass dude it's all round my
school take you guys know that during
you know when you guys start [ __ ]
during that bit with like right when I
used to DJ at a strip club
it's true dude that was a that was we
had that was a part there was a song by
enigma there was a super sexy spiritual
atmosphere so what happened but so so
when I'm when I'm at the strip club and
I'm playing this enigma song right and
there's this an it it's like me a cool
pot very popular enigma song it's like
spiritual and there's always Gregorian
chants and it's so spiritual and sexy
and then the music drops out and it's
silent and you hear a girl go
just for 2 seconds every time I got to
that part every time and never failed
I'd always mix in you [ __ ] Brian
County so there's the strippers hated
that I did that you don't do that but
the manager loved it so much he would
tell them stupid you shut the [ __ ] up go
do some lap dances every time I'd mix in
YouTube [ __ ] with an egg puff me up
we weren't really [ __ ] by the way I
was drunk I remember yeah I needed the
money
what was that for yeah an album that I
had I did an album on Warner Brothers in